so when should a student get in touch
with our being or with the mental health
services at their University so it
depends what situation that students in
like I say if they know that they
already diagnosed with a mental health
difficulty they want to get in touch
really as early as possible and even
filling out their prospective student
forms you know it does ask about
disability and mental health problems do
you come under that so they can fill
that out and then they be directed to
the access center for an assessment and
central DSA funding so then they'd you
know we'd already know about them and
can offer support straight away so for
students that know they have a diagnosed
mental health difficulty that's really
important at the point of applying and a
lot of students think that they don't
want to do that because University is
like a fresh slate and it's you know
fresh start which is really
understandable but it's also really
really stressful time it's the big
change and transition and actually for
for somebody that has you know any kind
of difficulties with mental health
actually that could be really unsettling
time and probably better to try and get
that support in place even if it's not
needed which hopefully you know it's not
but at least it's there then if they if
they do need that support and then
during the degree when should people but
when did winter people get in contact
well being if they feel that they might
be struggling well we're here for out of
the year and Jerry ten-time is obviously
our busiest time but we do have staff
here for the holiday times as well so
really there's no there's no time not to
get in contact basically if anybody
thinks that they are kind of really
struggling and like I say it might just
be a matter of coming in and having a
single session with somebody because
what we do here at Exeter which may vary
from university to University is we
don't just offer kind of counseling or
cognitive behavioral therapy if
somebody's just struggling and they feel
like they just need to see someone but
they don't quite need counseling
we do just have a single session
available which is like an intervention
in itself or maybe just come in and have
a workshop which is just a couple of
hours to get some more strategies and
techniques that you can apply again to
kind of manage that problem before it
feels like it gets out of hand or too
difficult so I'd say get in contact at
any point perhaps in here things but
I'm too difficult to feel like you can
manage it's very difficult to tear
yourself away from revision when there's
so much to do but a good advice really
is to try and if you have a schedule and
you have you know timeframes mapped out
when you want to be studying try and
include in that schedule things like